The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: All right, we're
going to get started here,
everyone.
And I know we have a lot going
on here at the lab today,
and I'm very pleased that those
of you decided to choose us
today over all the other
things that are going on.
So that's great,
I'm very pleased.
I wanted to say I think I've
provided feedback to everyone
who submitted their
earlier first homework
over the weekend, and I was
very impressed and pleased
by those of you who
did the homework.
I think you really embraced
the spirit of the homework
very well.
I know the homework
that just happened
is one that kind of
really builds on that.
For those of you who
didn't do the first one,
then you're kind of
left out a colon.
But I would like to give my
congratulations for those
who took on that
second homework, which
was significantly--
definitely required
a fair amount of contemplation
to sort of attempt at homework.
So I want to thank those
of you who did that.
So we're going to
get started here.
And so we're going to
bring up the slides here.
So we're going to be
getting a little bit more.
We're kind of entering the
second of the three sections.
We had these first
three courses here
that really was the first part.
Did a lot with motivation
and a lot with theory,
and now we're going to do stuff
that's a little bit more--
you know, we'll be
continuing that trend.
We'll still always have
plenty of motivation
and a little bit of theory,
but getting more and more
towards things that
feel like the things
you might actually really do.
And so we're kind of
entering into that next phase
of the course here.
So let's get started here.
So this is the lecture 03.
Pull up an example here
from some real data,
and talking about that.
Here is the outline
of the course.
Actually just before
we're doing that, sort
of somewhat mandatory for those
of you who are just joining us
or are watching on the
web and have jumped
to add to this lecture,
the title of the class
is Signal Processing
on Databases,
is two words that we don't
normally see together,
or two phrases.
Signal processing,
which is really
alluding to Detection
Theory, Formal Detection
theory, and its linear
algebraic foundations.
And databases, which
is really alluding
to dealing with strings, and
unstructured data, and graphs.
And so we're, in
this course, talking
about a technology, D4M, which
allows us to pull these two
views together.
And so again we're
now on the lecture 03,
and we will continue on this
journey that we have started.
Here's the outline.
A little bit of
history, I'm going
to talk about how the web became
the thing it is today, which
I think talks a lot about why
we invented the D4M technology.
So it's going to talk about
the specific gap that it fills,
and talk a little bit about
the D4M technology, some
of the results that we've had.
And then, hopefully today,
the demo is more substantive,
and so we'll spend
more time on that
than we did last time,
where last time was
more serious than the demo
was really fairly small.
So for those of you
who don't remember
back in the ancient primordial
days of the web, back
in the early 90s, this
is what it looked like.
So if I talk about the
hardware side of the web,
it was quite simple.
So there we go.
The hardware side of the
web was all Sun boxes.
We all had our Sun workstations,
and there were clients,
and there were servers,
and there were databases.
And the databases that we had
at the time were SQL databases.
Oracle was sort of really
kind of just beginning
to get going then.
Sybase was sort of a dominant
player at that stage.
This is sort of an example
of the very first modern web
page, or website,
that was built.
It was built by-- I'm sure
there are other people who
are doing very similar
things at same time,
so it's among the first.
It's difficult to-- not
going to be like Al Gore
and say I invented the internet.
But a friend of mine,
Don Beaudry and I,
were working for a company
called Vision Intelligence
Corporation, which
is now part of GE.
And we had a data set
and a SQL database,
and we wanted to
make it available.
And there are a lot
of thick client tools
that came with our Sybase
package for doing that,
but we found them a
little bit clunky.
And so a friend of mine, Don,
he downloaded this-- he said,
hey I found this new software.
I found a beta release of this
software called NCSA Mosaic.
And so for those who
don't know, NCSA Mosaic
was the first
browser, and it was
invented at the National
Center for Supercomputing
Applications.
And they released it.
And it was awesome.
It changed everything.
Just so you know, prior to that,
and not to disrespect anybody
who invented anything, but
HTTP and HTML were dying.
They had actually come out
in 1989, and everyone like,
this is silly.
What's this?
Why do I have to type this
HTTP and then this HTML,
and it's just very
clunky and stuff like.
That and it was getting its
clock pretty well cleaned
by another technology called
Gopher, which was developed
in the University
of Minnesota, which
was a much easier interface.
The server was a lot better.
It was a lot easier to
do links then in HTML.
And it was just a menu driven,
text based way to do that.
Well Mosaic created a
GUI front end to HTML
and allowed you
to have pictures,
and that changed everything.
That just absolutely-- and
it just sort of caught on
like wildfire.
But it was just a beta
at that point in time,
and I don't think you
could really do pictures,
but it rendered fonts nicely.
And Gopher did not.
Gopher was like just plain text.
So you could have like
underline, in bold,
and the links were very clear.
You could click at them.
You could even have
indents and bullets.
You could imagine organizing
with something that would
look like a web page today.
And so we had that,
and they're like,
oh well we'll talk to
our database using that.
We'll use you HTT put
to post a request.
The Mosaic server was
so bad, we actually
just used the Gopher server
to talk to the Mosaic browser.
And so we would do
puts, and then we
used a language called perl,
which many of you know,
because it actually had a
direct binding to Sybase.
And so we would take
that, format it,
and create SQL queries.
And then it would send us back
strings, which we would then
format as HTML, and input to
the browser, and it was great.
It was like very
nice, and it was
sort of the first modern web
page that we did in 1992.
And essentially a good fraction
of the internet kind of looks
like this today.
Our conclusion at that time was
that this browser was a really
lousy GUI, and that
HTTP was really
trying to be a file system,
but it was a really bad file
system.
And Perl was really
bad for analysis.
And SQL really wasn't--
it's good for credit cards
transactions, but it
wasn't really good for data
in and out.
So our conclusion was this
is an awful lot of work
just to use some documents,
and it won't catch on.
Our conclusion was
it won't catch on.
So with that
conclusion, maybe I'm
underscoring my judgment
for the entire course
that we decided
this was a bad idea.
So after that we had sort
of what we call the Cambrian
Explosion of the internet,
which is we had an explosion.
On the hardware side, we
had big, giant data centers
merging servers and
databases, which is great.
We had all these new types of
hardware technologies here,
laptops, and
tablets, and iPhones,
and all that kind of stuff.
So the hardware technology went
forward in leaps and bounds.
And then the browsers really
took off, all of them.
We have all these
different browsers.
You can still see, I
have the mosaic logo
back there still a little bit,
because they're still showing.
For those of you who don't know,
the author of Mosaic and NCSA
was a guy by the name
of Marc Andreessen.
He left NCSA and
formed a company called
Netscape, which actually,
at a moment in time
was the dominant--
they were the internet.
They got crushed, although
I think Marc Andreessen made
a fair amount of money.
But they did open source
all their software,
and so they basically rewrote
Mosaic from the ground up,
and that became Mozilla
and Firefox and all that.
So that's still around today.
Safari may have
borrowed from this.
I don't really know.
When Netscape was
dominating the internet,
Microsoft needed to-- first
they thought the internet was
going to be a fad.
And then they're like,
all right this is serious.
We need a browser.
And so Mosaic had
actually been spun out
of the University of
Illinois into a company
called Spyglass, which may
actually still exist today.
And then Microsoft
bought the browser,
which was the original
NCSA Mosaic code,
and that became in
Internet Explorer.
So it's still around today.
This is Chrome, and
as far as I know
chrome is a complete
rewrite from the ground up.
And probably some of the
other, like Opera, and other
browsers that around
today are completely--
but they still use it.
It's a browser to use.
HTML still uses the
basic put get syntax.
SQL, we're still using it today.
We have all whole
explosion of technologies,
Oracle being very
dominant, but my SQL,
SQL Server, or other
types of things,
Sybase still
around, very common.
And we still have
two major servers
out there, Apache and Windows.
So Apache was the Mosaic server.
And just so you
know, Apache was--
it's a patchy server,
meaning it was very buggy.
So it was the a patchy server,
and that became Apache.
So that was the
new Mosaic server,
became Apache because
it was a patchy server.
And I bet they had
borrowed code from Gopher,
so that's why the
Gopher, I think,
is still showing
there a little bit.
We've had a proliferation
of languages
that are very similar.
So people, in terms of
gluing these two together,
Java, et cetera, all
that type of stuff.
But the important
thing to recognize
is that this whole architecture
was not put together,
because somehow we felt the web
browser was the optimal tool,
or SQL was the optimal
tool, or these languages are
the optimal tool.
They were just things
that were laying down
to could be repurposed
for this job.
And so that's why they're not
necessarily optimal things.
But nevertheless,
our conclusion has
to be slightly revised
that it would not catch on,
because obviously
it did catch on.
The desire to share
information was so great
that it overcame the
high barrier to entry
just to set up on a web
page or something like that.
Now things have
changed significantly.
We're not the first
people to observe
that this original
architecture is somewhat
broken for this type of model.
And so today the web looks
a lot more like this.
You see all of our awesome
client hardware which is great.
We have servers
and databases that
have now moved in type
of the data center
into shipping containers
and other types of things,
which is great.
Increasingly, our
interfaces will look
a lot more like video games.
I would tell you that a
typical app on the iPad
feels a lot more like a video
game than a browser, which
is great, so we're really kind
of moving beyond the browser
is the dominant way for
getting our information.
And companies like
Google and others
recognize that, if you're just
presenting data to people,
and you're not doing say
credit card transactions,
then a lot of the features of
SQL in those types of databases
are maybe more than you
need, and you can actually
make these sort of
very scalable databases
more simply that are
called triple stores.
And so Google Bigtable being
the original sort of one.
Riak is another.
Cassandra is another.
HBase is another.
Accumulo, which is the one we
use in this class, is another.
So this whole new technology
space has really driven that
and has made a
lot more scalable.
But unfortunately, in
the middle here, we're
still very much left with
much of the same technology.
And this is kind of the last
piece, this sort of glue.
And so our conclusion
is now that it's
a lot of work to
view a lot of data,
but it's a pretty great
view, and we can really
view a lot of data.
But we still have
this middle problem.
There's this gap.
And so we're trying
to address that gap.
And so we address
that gap with D4M.
So D4M is formally
designed from the ground up
to be something that
is really designed
to work on triples,
the kind of data
we store in these
modern databases,
and do the kind of
analysis in less code
than you would otherwise.
So D4M, which stands for Dynamic
Distributed Dimension Data
model, which is
sometimes in quotes,
databases for Matlab,
because it happens
to be written in Matlab.
It connects the
triple stores, which
can view their data as
very large, sparse matrices
of triples with the mathematical
concepts of associative arrays
that we talked about last class.
That's essentially
what D4M does for you.
So that's kind of one sort of
holistic view of the technology
space that we're
dealing with here.
Another way to view at it, which
I'm going to talk a little bit
about how the technologies that
we have brought this to you.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about LLGrid
and what we do there, because
you're using your LLGrid
accounts for this, and
so I want to tell you
a little bit about that.
So LLGrid is the
core supercomputer
at Lincoln Laboratory.
And we're here to help with
all your computing needs.
Likewise, we're here to
help with your D4M needs.
If you have a
project, and you think
it would be useful to
use D4M in that project,
please contact us.
You don't have to
just take this class
and think that
you're on your own.
I mean, we are a service.
We will help you do the
schemas, get the code going,
get it sort of adapted
to your problem.
That's what we do.
LLGrid, we have
actually well over this,
but just so I don't have
to keep changing the slide.
We always say it's about 500
users, about 2000 processors.
It's more than that.
To our knowledge, it's
really the world's
only desktop interactive
supercomputer.
It's dramatically easier to use
than any other supercomputer.
And as a result,
as an organization,
we have the highest fraction
of staff using supercomputing
on a regular basis
of any organization,
just because it's so easy.
And it's also kind of been
the foundation, the vision,
for supercomputing in the
entire state of Massachusetts.
All of our ideas
have been adopted
by other universities in the
state and moving forward.
Not really the technology that
we're talking about today,
but something that is
really kind of the bread
and butter of LLGrid, is our
Parallel Matlab technology,
which is now going
to be celebrating
its 10th anniversary this year.
And it's really a
way to allow people
to do parallel programming
relatively easily.
D4M interacts seamlessly
with this technology,
and so you will also be
doing parallel database codes
with this technology.
So we have this thing
called Parallel Matlab.
If you're an LLGrid user,
you are entitled to,
or you almost always get
the book on Parallel Matlab.
And it allows you to
take things like matrices
and chop them up very easily
to do complicated calculations.
And almost every single parallel
program that you want to write
can be written with just
the addition of a handful
of additional functions.
And we get to use what is
called a distributed arrays
parallel program model,
which is generally
recognized as by far the best
of all the parallel programming
models, if you are comfortable
with a multi-dimensional
arrays.
Everyone at MIT is,
so this is easy.
However this is
not generally true.
Thinking in matrices is
not a universal skill,
or universal training, and so
it is a bit of-- sometimes we do
say this is software for the 1%.
So you know, it is
not for everyone.
But if you do have this
knowledge and background,
it allows you to do
things very naturally.
And as you know,
we've talked about all
of our associated arrays as
looking at data in matrices,
and so these two technologies
come together very nicely.
And we are really the only
place in the world where you
can routinely use this model.
This is the dominant
model that people
use when they do parallel
programming, which
is generally-- and you
might say, well why do I
say it's the best?
Well we run contests.
There's a contest every year
where we bake off the best
parallel programming models,
and distributed arrays
in high level environments
wins every year.
And so it's kind
of the best model
if you can understand them.
It wouldn't be a class
on computing in 2012
unless we talked
about the cloud,
so we definitely need
to talk about the cloud.
And to make it
simple for people,
we're going to divide the
cloud into sort of two halves.
You can subdivide the cloud
into many, many different
components.
There's what we call utility
cloud computing, which is what
most people use the cloud for.
So gmail, what are
enterprise services,
calendars online, all
that kind of stuff,
basic data sharing,
photo sharing,
and stuff like that, that's
what we call utility cloud
computing.
You can do human
resources on the cloud.
You can do accounting
on the cloud.
All this type of stuff
that's on the cloud,
and it's a very, very
successful business.
What we mostly focus on is what
is called data intensive cloud
computing.
It's based on Hadoop and
other types of technologies.
But even still, a lot
of that is technologies
that are used by large
scale cloud companies,
but they don't really
share with you.
Google, although it's
often called Hadoop,
Google doesn't
actually use Hadoop.
Hadoop is based on a small part
of the Google infrastructure.
Google's infrastructure is
vastly larger than that.
And they don't just let
anybody log into and say,
oh go ahead mine
all the Google data.
They expose it to
services, allowing
you to do some of that, but the
core technology that they do,
they don't expose.
In all large companies, they
don't expose that to you.
They give you selected
services and such.
But this is really what
we're focused on is,
this data intensive computing.
If I want to further subdivided
the cloud from an implementer's
perspective, if you own a
lot of computing hardware,
I mean hundreds of
kilowatts or megawatts
of computing hardware,
you're most likely doing
one of these four things.
You could be doing traditional
supercomputing, which we all
know and love, which
is sort of closest
to what we do in LLGrid.
You could do a traditional
database management system,
so every single time you use a
credit card, make a purchase,
you're probably connecting
to a traditional database
managed system.
You could be doing
enterprise computing,
which mostly, this day and
age, is run out of VMware.
So this is the LLGrid logo.
And so you could be doing that.
So that's all the things
I earlier mentioned.
Or this new kid on
the block, big data,
which is all the buzz today,
using java and MapReduce
and other types of things.
The important thing to
recognize is these four areas,
each of these are multi tens of
billions of dollars industry.
The IT world has
gotten large enough
that we now see specialization
down to the hardware level.
The hardware, the processors,
that these folks use
is different.
Likewise for these
folks and these folks.
You see specialization
of chips, now,
to these different
types of things.
So each of these at the center
of a multi-billion dollar
ecosystem, and they
each have pros and cons.
And sometimes you can do
your mission wholly in one,
but sometimes you have to cross.
And when you do cross, it
can be quite a challenge,
because these worlds are
not necessarily compatible.
And I would say, just to help
people to understand Hadoop,
one must recognize that
Java is the first class
citizen in the Hadoop world.
The entire infrastructure
is written in Java.
It's designed so that
if you only know Java,
you can actually administer
and manage a cluster, which
is why it's become so popular.
There are so many
Java programmers,
and now they just know Java,
and they downloaded Hadoop,
and they have rudimentary
access to some computer systems
they can sort of cobble
together a cluster.
I should say the
same thing occurred
in the C in the Fortran
commune in the mid 90s.
There was a
technology called NPI,
in fact this is the NPI logo
today, which allowed you,
if you knew C, Fortran had
rudimentary access on a network
of workstations, you could
create a cluster with NPI.
And that really sort
of began the whole sort
of parallel cluster
computing revolution.
This does the same
thing in Java,
and so for Java
programmers it's been
a huge success in that regard.
Just so you know where
we sit-in with that,
so we have a LLGrid
here, which has really
made traditional
supercomputing feel interactive
and on demand and elastic,
so that's one of the things
that we do that's
LLGrid, very unique.
You launch your job.
It runs immediately.
That is different than the
way every other supercomputing
center in the country is run.
Most supercomputing centers are
run by, you write your program,
and you launch it, and you
wait until the queue says
that it is run.
And in fact, some
centers will even
use, as a metric of success,
how long their wait is.
It's kind of like a
restaurant, right?
How many years do
you have to wait
to get a good reservation,
or a good doctor right?
And I remember someone saying,
oh our system is so successful
that our wait is a week.
You hit submit and you will have
to wait a week to run your job.
That's not really
consistent with the way
we do business around here.
You're under very
tight deadlines.
So we created a very different
type of system 10 years ago,
which sort of feels more
like what you people are
trying to do in the cloud.
In the Hadoop community,
there's been a lot of work
to try and make databases.
What these technologies give
you is sort of efficient search,
and so there are a
number of databases
that have been developed
that sit on top of Hadoop,
HBase being one, and
Accumulo being another.
Which to my knowledge is
the highest performance
open source triple
store in the world,
and probably will remain that
way for a very long time.
And so we will be using
the Accumulo database.
And then we've created
bindings to that.
So we have our D4M
technology, which allows
you to bind you to databases.
And we also have something
called LLGrid MapReduce.
MapReduce is sort of the
core programming model
within the Hadoop community.
It's such a trivial
model, it almost
doesn't even deserve a name.
It's basically like, write a
program given a list of files.
Each program runs on
each file independently.
I mean it's a very,
very simple model.
It's been around since the
beginning of computing,
but the name has become
popularized here,
and we now have a way to do
MapReduce right in LLGrid.
It's very easy, and
people enjoy it.
You can, of course,
do the same thing
with other technology in
LLGrid, but for those people,
particularly if you're
writing job or-- not Matlab.
We don't recommend people
use this for Matlab,
because we have better
technologies for doing that.
But if you're using Python,
or Java, or other programs,
then MapReduce is there for you.
As we move towards combining--
so our big vision here
is to combine big
compute and big data,
and so we have a
whole stack here
as we deal with
new applications,
texts, cyber, bio, other
types of things, the new APIs
that people write, the new
types of distributed databases.
So it's really
affecting everything.
Just an example of the
Hadoop architecture.
You've had this course.
You should at least
have a few minutes
so that if someone asked,
well what is Hadoop,
you know what it does.
This is the basic architecture.
So you have a Hadoop
MapReduce job.
You submit it, and it
goes to a JobTracker.
The JobTracker then breaks that
up into subtasks, each of which
has its own tracker.
Those tasks then get sent to the
DataNodes in the architecture,
and it gets those
DataNodes, and NameNode
keeps track of the actual
names of the things.
Just a very simple
a Hadoop cluster.
This is the different
types of the nodes
that are in, and
processes in architecture.
Hadoop's strengths and
weaknesses, well it
does allow you to distribute
processing a large data.
Best use case is, let's say
you had enormous number of log
files, and you decided you only
wanted to search them once,
for one string.
That's the perfect
use case for Hadoop.
If you decide, though, that
you would like to actually do
more than one search, then
it doesn't necessarily
always make sense.
So it's basically
designed to run grep
on an enormous number of files.
And I kid you not, there
are companies today
that actually do this,
like at production scale.
All their analytics are
done by just grepping
enormous numbers of log files.
Needless to say that the entire
database community cringes,
and rolls over in their graves
if they are not alive, at this.
Because we have
solved this problem
by indexing our data, and that
allows you to do fast search.
And people, that's why
people have invented
databases like
HBase and Accumulo,
which would sit on top of Hadoop
because they recognize that,
really, if you're going
to search more than once,
you should index your data.
Again, it is very scalable.
It is fundamentally
designed to have extremely
unreliable hardware in it.
So it is quite resilient.
It does this
resiliency at a cost.
It relies on a significant
amount of replication.
Typically the standard
replication in a Hadoop cluster
is a factor of 3.
If you're in the high
performance storage business,
this also makes you
cringe, because you're
paying 3x for your storage.
We have techniques like RAID,
which allow us to do that.
But again, the expertise
required to set up a cluster
and do 3x replication
is relatively low,
and so that makes
it very appealing
to many, many, many folks, and
so it's very useful for that.
Some of the difficulties,
the scheduler in Hadoop
is very immature.
Schedulers are
very well defined.
There's about two or
three standard schedulers
in the supercomputing community.
They're each about 20 years old.
They all have the
same 200 features,
and you need about 200
features to really do
a proper scheduler.
Hadoop is about four
or five years old,
and it's got about
that many features.
And so you do often have
to deal with collisions.
It's easy for one user
to hog and monopolise
the entire cluster.
You're often dealing
with various overheads
from the scheduler itself.
And this is well known
to the Hadoop community.
They're working on it
actively, and we'll
see all that-- it's not an
easy multi-user environment.
And as I've said
before, it fundamentally
relies on the fact that
the JVM is on every node.
Because when you're sending
a program to every node,
the interpreter for that
must exist on every node.
And by definition,
the only language
that you're guaranteed to
have on every node in a Hadoop
cluster is Java.
Any other language,
any other tool,
has to be installed
and become a part
of the image for
the entire system
so that it can be
run on every node.
So that is something that
one has to be aware of.
And we've certainly
seen it's like, oh
I wrote these great programs
in another language.
And it's like, well
can't I just run them?
It's like no, that
doesn't exist.
Even distributing a fat
binary can be difficult,
because it has to be distributed
through the Hadoop Distributed
File system.
All data is distributed
there, and that
is not-- you have to essentially
write a wrapper program that
then recognizes where
to get your binary,
and then exacts that thing
and it can be tricky.
But the basic LLGrid
MapReduce architecture
simplifies this significantly,
although this maybe
doesn't look like it.
Essentially you call
LLGrid MapReduce.
It launches a bunch of what
are called mapper tasks.
It runs them on your
different input files.
When they have done, they've
created output files.
And then runs another program.
If you specified, it
then combines the output.
So that's the basic
model of MapReduce,
which is you have what's
called a map program
and a reduced program,
and the map program is
given a list of files.
It runs those
programs on at a time.
Each one of them
generates an outpoint,
and a reduce program
pulls them all together.
All right, so that's a
little tutorial on Hadoop,
because I felt an obligation
to explain that to you.
We couldn't be a big data course
without having doing that.
But it's very simple,
and very popular,
and I expect it to maintain it's
popular for a very long time.
I think it will
evolve and get better,
but for the vast majority
of people on planet Earth,
this is really the
most accessible form
of parallel computing technology
that they have available.
So we should all be aware of
Hadoop, and its existence,
and what it can do.
Because many of our
customers use Hadoop,
and we need to work with them.
All right, so getting
back now to D4M.
I think I've mentioned
a lot of this before.
The core concept of D4M is
multi-dimensional associative
array.
Again, D4M is designed
to sort of overcomes.
For those of us who have
more mathematical expertise,
we can do much more
sophisticated things
than you might be
able to do in Hadoop.
Again, it allows you to look at
your data in four ways at once.
You can view it as 2D matrices,
and reference rows and columns
with strings, and have
values that are strings.
It's one to one
with a triple store,
so you can easily
connect to databases.
Again, it looks like matrices
so you can do linear algebra.
And also between the duality
between adjacency matrices
and graphs, you can also think
about your data as graphs.
This is composable,
as I've said before.
Almost all of our operations
that I perform an associated
rate of return another
associative array,
and so we can do things like add
them, subtract them, and them,
or them, multiply them, and we
can do very complicated queries
very easily.
And these can work on
associative arrays.
And if we're bound to tables,
they can also do that.
Speaking of tables,
I've already talked
about our schema in this
class that we always use.
So if your standard data
might look like this,
say this is a cyber record
of a source IP, domain,
and destination IP, this is sort
of the standard tabular view.
We explode it by taking the
source, pending the value to it
which creates this very
large, sparse table here
which will naturally go
into our triple store.
Of course, by itself
it doesn't really
gain as anything, because
most tables either
are row based or column based.
The databases that we are
working with a row based,
which allow you to do
fast look up of row key.
However, once we've exploded
the schema, if we also
store the transpose, we now can
index everything here quickly
and effectively to the user.
It looks like we have
indexed every single string
in the database with
one schema, which
is very nice, very
powerful stepping stone
for getting results.
All right, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about what we have done here.
So I'm just going to go
over some basic analytics
and show you a
little bit more code.
So for example,
here is our table.
So this could be viewed
as the sparse matrix.
We have various source IPs here.
And I want to just compute
some very elementary statistics
on this data.
I should say, computing
things like sums and averages
may sound like not very
sophisticated statistic.
It's still
extraordinarily powerful,
and we are amazed
at how valuable it
is, because it usually
shows you right
away the bad data in your data.
And you will always
have bad data.
And this is probably
the first bit of value
add we provide to
almost any customer
that we work with on D4M,
is it's the first time
anybody's actually
sort of looked
at their data in totality,
and been able to do
these types of things.
And so usually the first
thing we do is like,
all right we've loaded
their data in schema,
and we've done some basic sum.
And then we'll say, do you know
that you have the following
stuck on switches?
You know, 8% of
your data all has
this value in this column,
which absolutely can't be right,
you know?
And 8% could be a low enough
number that you might not just
encounter it through
routine traversal,
but it will stand out in just
the most rudimentary histogram,
extremely.
And so that's an incredibly
valuable piece of [INAUDIBLE].
Oh my goodness, they'll
usually be like,
there's something
broken in our system.
Or you'll be like,
you have this column,
but it's almost never
filled in, and it sure
looks like it
should be filled in,
so these switches are stuck off.
I encourage, when you
do the first thing,
to just kind of do the
basic statistics on the data
and see where things are working
and where things are broken.
And usually you can
then either fix them.
And most of the time
when we tell a customer,
it's like, we're
just letting you
know these are
issues in your data.
We can work around them.
We can sort of ignore
them and still proceed,
or you can fix them yourselves.
And almost always
they're like, no we
want to fix that ourselves.
That's something
that's fundamentally
broken in our system.
We want to make sure that
that data is correct.
Because usually
that data is flowing
into all other places
doing a being acted on,
and so that's one thing
we're going to do.
So we're going to do some
basic statistics here.
We're going to compute how many
times each column type appears.
We're going to compute how
many times each type appears.
We'll compute some covariance
matrices, just some very, very
simple types of things here.
All right, let's move on here.
So this is the basic
implementation.
So we're going to
give it a set of rows
that we're looking at here.
This could be very large.
We have a table binding,
T, so we say, please
go and get me all those rows.
So we get the whole
swath of rows,
and that will return that
as an associative array.
And then, normally I
shorten this is double logi,
since the table always
contain strings,
it return strings
values, the first thing
we knew it was going
to get rid of those,
because we're going to do math.
So we turn them into logicals,
and then we turn them back
into double so we can do math.
You can actually pass
regular expressions.
You can also do that
starts with command.
We want to get the source IP.
We're just interested
in source IP domain.
And the first thing we do is
find some popular columns.
So we just type sum, and that
shows up popular columns.
If we want to find
popular pairs,
it's covariance matrix
calculation there,
or square in and find domains
with many destination IPs.
An example in this data set
is this was the most popular
in the data set that we had.
These were the most popular
things that appeared here.
And you can see, this is
all fairly reasonable stuff,
LLBean, lot of New England
Patriots fans in this data set,
a lot of ads, Staples.
These are the types of things
it shows you right away.
Here's the covariance
matrix of this data.
So as you can see,
it's symmetric.
Obviously there is
a diagonal, and it
has the bipartite structure.
That is, there is no destination
to destination IP links.
And we have source IP the
destination, domain, and all
that type of stuff exactly.
The covariance matrix is
often extremely helpful thing
to look at, because it
will be the first time
it shows you the full
interrelated structure
of your data.
And you can quickly identify
dense rows, dense columns,
blocks, chunks, some things
where you want to look at,
chunks that aren't
going to be interesting
because they're very, very
dense or very, very sparse.
Again a very, very just
sort of survey type of tool.
A little shout out
here to our colleagues
in the other group, who
developed structured knowledge
space.
Structured knowledge space is
a very powerful analytic data
set.
I kind of tell people it's
like the Google search
where when you
type a search key,
it starts guessing what
your next answer is.
But Google does that based on
sort of a long sort of analysis
of all the different types
of searches people have done,
and it can make a good guess.
SKS does that much more deeply,
in that it maintains a database
on a collection of documents.
And in this case, if
you type Afghanistan,
will then actually go
and count the occurrences
of different types of
entities in those documents,
and then show you what
the possible next key word
choices can be, so in
the actual data itself,
not based on a set
of cached queries
and other types of things.
I don't really know what
Google actually does.
I'm just guessing.
I'm sure they do use some
data for guiding their search,
but this is a fairly
sophisticated analytic.
And one of the big
sort of wins for we
knew we were on the
right track with D4M
is that this has
been implemented
in hundreds or thousands
of lines of job at SQL.
And I'm going to show
you how we implement it
in one line in D4M.
So let's go over that algorithm.
So here's an example of what
my data might look like.
I have a bunch of
documents here.
I have a bunch of entities,
where an entity appears
in a document.
I have a dot.
I'm going to have my
associative array over here,
which is matching from
the strings to the reals.
And my two facets are just going
to be two columns names here,
so I'm going to pick
a facet y1 and y2.
So I'm going to pick
these two columns.
All right, so basically
that's what this does.
This says get me
y1 and get me y2.
I'm using this bar
here to say I'm
going to knock away the
facet name afterwards
so I can and them together.
So that gets me all the
documents that basically
contain both UN and
Carl, and then I
can go and compute
the counts that you
saw in the previous
page there just
by doing this matrix multiply.
So and them, I
transpose them, and I
matrix multiply to get them
together, and then there we go.
All right, so now I'm
going to get into the demo,
and I think we have
plenty of time for that.
I'll sort of set it up, and
they'll take short break.
People can have
cookies, and then we
will get into the demo, which
really begins to show you
a way to use D4M on real data.
So the data that we're
going to work with here
is the Reuters Corpus.
So this was a corpus of data
released in 2000 to help spur
research in this community.
We're very grateful
for Reuters to do this.
They gave the data
to NIST who actually
stewards the data sets.
It's a set of
Reuters news reports
over this particular
time frame, the mid 90s,
and it's like 800,000 total.
And what we have done,
we're not actually
working with the
straight Reuters data,
we've run it through
various parsers that
have extracted just
the entities, so
the people, the places,
and the organization.
So it's sort of a summary.
It's a very terse summarization
of the data, if that.
It's really sort of
a derived product.
The data is power
law, so if we look
at the documents per
entity, you see here
that certain people, places,
and organizations, appear.
A few of them appear lots
of places, and most of them
appear in just a few documents,
and you see the same thing
when you look at the
entities per documents.
So there's
essentially, could view
this is computing the
in degrees and the out
degrees of this
bipartite graphs.
And it has the classic
power law shape
that we expect to
see in our data.
So with that, we're
going to go in the demo.
And just to summarize,
so just recall,
the evolution of
the web is really
created a new class
of technologies.
We really see the web moving
towards game style interfaces,
triple store databases,
and technologies
like D4M for doing analysis,
very new technology.
And just so that
we, for the record,
there is no
assignment this week.
So for those of you who are
still doing the assignments,
yay.
The example, actually won't
do both of these today,
we'll just do one of them.
Oh and I keep
making this mistake.
I'll fix it.
I'll fix it later.
But it's in the
examples directory.
We've now moved on to the
second subfolder, apps,
entity analysis.
And you guys are encouraged
to run those examples, which
we will now do shortly.
So we will take a short
five minute break,
and then continue
on with the demo.